[Music]
in grocery segregation news yes
submitted by r1 tonnes dumplings and to
find out our wontons dumplings you have
to hit the subscribe button right now
and the Bell because we want to get to
that toe Billy embark
yay celebrity chef David Chang says the
ethnic food aisles in grocery stores are
racist why does it have it does it have
a Chinese guy with the eyes go like this
and in a [ __ ] thing didn't Dean Dean
Dean asked is it segregated I'm a big
fan of him [ __ ] him
chef I love all the shows but Gio it
helps you find the [ __ ] no I hate it
because I have to think that it's in it
then it's own aisle mix with the Asian
[ __ ] and like all this other [ __ ] run
like if it's rice just putting the
[ __ ] rice I'll and I'll decide but
then there's white people right that
sucks and just a good Asian rice I know
but I don't want to go to a separate
aisle to get my rice just put in the
[ __ ] rice aisle take it back man know
what you [ __ ] ticket no you're a rice
pilaf lover I'm not I like you I like
jambalaya rice that's shitty rice for me
it's like if I I don't even go to
American markets to get Asian products
anyway but then it is convenient cuz
when you go and you want to make a
Asians like dish or whatever all the
things are there so you have to go all
over the place already gonna find you at
the grocery store please don't take this
away from me
like I like any time you can't I need to
go get rice paper or some [ __ ] because
Nikki's making sushi or something I'm
like oh man I want to even more raisins
find it like I wanna I want a Chinese
guy doing kung fu and [ __ ] and and he's
standing there giving samples out like
and then like I'm like oh [ __ ] I'm in
the Chinese aisle and then and I'm like
but it's not even Chinese out it's an
ethnic aisle because so like when you're
it makes you feel like I'm I finally get
to go into another world so I'm not
Ralph's I'm buying my normal stuff right
like I don't know fruits or juice or
whatever and then sometimes you're like
you're looking for spices and then
you're like aha
the spice that I want bay leaves or
something hate it
not here exactly I'll you're so happy
you go because you get to see the
Mexican candles you see like ponzu sauce
Oh
vermicelli I like oh I hate it I feel
what about [ __ ] you is that they
don't put shampoo next to [ __ ] bath
soap what is with that [ __ ] do they put
a next thing up it's like in a whole
nother aisle with the deodorant yeah
exactly
that's racist that's a [ __ ] also you
ever been in 99 Ranch
they have like a Thai section a
different country section it's the same
[ __ ] I like that
me too and hopefully find every throw I
see like a fat white guy with no shirt
on and just overalls and that's the
barbecue section he's grilling yeah if
the whole grocery store was like USA
Canada whatever and now if that makes
sense to me instead of just pushing all
the [ __ ] colored [ __ ] in one little
functional aisle you don't like be able
to get all your Mexican stuff in one
section is that you gave where I'm
trying to look for a specific spice so
my mango spice aisle and now I'm like oh
wait yeah this is the [ __ ] Mexican
spice let me go to the ethnic aisle
listen turn it down because I'm Mexican
guy with a sombrero handing it to you
isn't that happy and it gives you a
churro
yeah any supermarket that'll give you a
churro is probably a good idea yeah yeah
HRT but would you get mad though would
you be like this is inappropriate why
you have to wear a poncho and a [ __ ]
sombrero if I didn't see a white [ __ ]
you as a person why does he think this
racist yeah a big fan please please like
like it's a negativity the celebrity
chef all this shows are [ __ ] awesome
what's his name David Chang he's on
Netflix our so-called delicious it's a
really dope show here's another one
before that what was that one called I
don't know they're really good shows hmm
not chef's table right have you guys
ever been to his restaurant and I went
to both of them well I went to one of
Vegas that one's really good we got a
smoked branzino and ramen and it went to
the other one caught once caught
Momofuku ones called Moo [ __ ] ooh that
one's what you're real you're
[ __ ] fan dude Lincoln Heights [ __ ] I
know but you said [ __ ] this guy like if
he he he's already out he's not watching
I'm a big fan David knows already got
heard [ __ ] this guy any close I hope you
didn't because you should have been
subscribed oh yeah he said that there's
an invisible ceiling on some supermarket
items Italian products that were once
marginalized such as olive oils and
vinegars are now routinely integrated
into grocery store aisles Chinese
Japanese and Latino foods remain stuck
in their own sections he says that it
isn't about acceptance among the
mainstream it's about segregating these
foods from the rest so he says growing
up as like an Asian American he he
whenever he would go to the grocery
store he'd be reminded that he will
never be part of America and I like that
he will forever special I thought that
was a new thing because I don't remember
them because I started I remember it my
whole life I never noticed the Asian
section yes sriracha action there was
just the ethnic section anyone ever Nick
food or international foods yeah I never
seen it but they didn't even ask to
watch it it also depends on the region
in which but sriracha is an Asian so
it's just made out here depends on the
rules where the for even for us
I remember if we wanted ajun ingredients
you had to go to Asian market it's just
now they started picking up sriracha and
real Asian American said that too as
well like you know he would be he would
go to Korean grocery stores to get
things but then sometimes when you go to
the American grocery stores and he would
see that there's an aisle specific for
his culture like you know for Asian or
Latin cultures he just felt like now
we're more separate like we're never
gonna be part of America because we have
our own section do you feel it is to not
have it there at all
so he doesn't so he's like it should be
integrated with everything I like hot
sauce is hot
but the Tabasco next to sriracha is that
of the sriracha and its own agency I
feel like it's it's steps you know like
it didn't have before but now they have
it so it's like a baby steps and then
I'm sure a baby steps I think it's been
a minute that Latinos have been here
Chinese people have been here like but
like I feel like maybe maybe they put no
UK foods in our store like it's actually
way more convenience you just have a
Latino section it is so in terms of I
mean I guess you know it can be
convenient cuz you're like oh yeah I
know I can get all everything in this
one section but then it kind of sucks
because it's like well like like your
[ __ ] is so different it needs its own
aisle a post is just putting it out for
everyone to see and everyone to the
library it's like there's a fiction
section and there's a nonfiction section
it just helps you find [ __ ] there's a
lot but pasta like he was saying is
Italian put it like in the ethnic
section well because pasta is not
Italian it came from China okay then put
it in the ethnic section look if you
really go back far enough all foods came
to me right this just isn't it simply
just the amount of demand is you know
like it fits like why there's no supply
right like now with the demand that's
gonna equal the supply right if there's
no demand for it they're not even gonna
have a shelf for it yeah so I feel like
more people eat I don't know one time
faster yeah whatever Ben is gonna
gradually get into this and they do with
veggies if there's enough people eating
like tortillas don't the tortillas in
the car like that as soon as they
started doing that in the regular aisle
I was like holy [ __ ] this is I was that
was like a proud moment for me cuz I'm
like holy [ __ ] we're American yeah I'm
like [ __ ] we just got accepted into
[ __ ] growls you're still in the
ethnic session no it's not it's not no
it's like I think it could be like with
the bread or that same eye oh when you
rent a car dealership when you saw a
Subaru did you cry because you're like
we [ __ ] did it we're in Mexicans all
have their own car oh sorry
you got Subarus or Mexican no no it's
not super I was talking about I was
talking about one thing in gnostics is
Moslems know
the car dealership that color slim moans
what's that one I don't know what that
way so the Italian one used to be a part
of the ethnic section and then they
pulled it out is that what you mean yes
but I do want to tell you the other side
of this so so this guy who is the senior
vice president of Goya foods which is a
Mexican food I've seen the stronger yeah
I like their beans yes
so he says that it's not it's actually
more convenient and way more profitable
to have these international sections
these ethnic sections because we're out
of grocery stores there's over 42,000
items that they can be looking for so if
they're trying to there if they're
trying to cook a specific cuisine that
is not part of like the like more
Americanized cuisine yeah yeah but he's
looking at it from a profit standpoint
where I'm like cool as a business person
of course you're gonna love it because
not everyone's getting it or they know
to go there but for me as someone like
I'm saying the tortilla example I just
felt like oh [ __ ] really it's a David
yeah we're I'm like oh [ __ ] I'm like at
the same playing field now with like
like white people I'm like that's
[ __ ] tight like we're making it we're
making an impact here like that's crazy
because when I go to the grocery store
I'm thinking about what am I gonna cook
today
yeah I'm not I'm not thinking about I'm
like white people what I'm thinking
about Pat time okay I'm gonna make pad
thai where can I get all the ingredients
oh great everything's here let me just
oh you know what what I want to make
with Pad Thai though is I want to make
[ __ ] tom yum soup ilysm it's like
yeah like you don't think about it until
you see it cuz I relate to that when it
comes to like when I saw Wonder Woman I
didn't realize like and also the marbles
the last movie that they had were all
the female characters came in and
they're all badasses like I actually got
emotional cuz I'm like holy [ __ ] I don't
I've never seen women in a power
position like that yeah it's been until
it happens where you're like oh wow yeah
but if I hear so watch it next to
[ __ ] Tabasco I'm not gonna shed a
tear and be like oh my
[ __ ] American you know like all his
angels that's the power that was
powerful you were way more sexualized
like they weren't very like like they
were kinda Marvel chicks who's wearing
the skin tight [ __ ]
sure it's it'll DEATH BATTLE oh that's
just the American dream the difference
was though like at least with like
Wonder Woman or whatever she was like
the leading role she's the badass she
didn't have to lean on a dude like
Charlie what who can't be Charlie you
know what I mean it was like her [ __ ]
and she came from like a planet of like
strong ass women exactly yeah yeah
that's that's interesting
because when I saw that scene I was the
opposite I was like oh of course we
wouldn't have power they don't have to
strongly say it you know it's just
different perspectives I think if you've
never been represented I guess yeah yeah
that makes sense though you don't want
one proud moment I had was I was at
Ralph's and I was at the grocery section
I mean the produce section and I was
looking at bok choy and [ __ ] and on the
tag is it Asian pride because that's the
name of the company that's the same
thing I felt then weren't you like
that's tight like we made it but still
go to Asian markets for green eyes I was
like I was like the tag says Asian pride
you call your company Asian pride yeah
so there's two sides to this so kind of
interesting it's an interesting topic
yeah whatever is convenient for me yes
it's convenient for me to have all the
ethnic stuff in one place because and
you could just get like it is convenient
yes enchilada sauce it's in for me it's
like it's like one of my Netflix on my
action movies Oh sick too all in one
spot this is so easy it's cute yeah
helps right I get it but my own
mentality is more like Gio or it's like
I want a sauce let me go to the sauce
aisle oh [ __ ] this is from Mexican or if
I want to feel powerful I just go to the
Chinese market with all the white people
[ __ ] on in the corner you know I mean I
look [ __ ] rule the world and they
only have two choices of Kenya well if I
go all the Americans all the American
[ __ ] is highly oppressed in that
supermarket and you're like yeah they
don't have
your two cents these are mine mm-hmm but
my seasons on top of course you [ __ ] I
wish they carry different types of milk
at Asian markets more than my goat's
milk it's not very diverse it's not
diverse it's like milk out there's no
like almond milk or milk or oh I have to
go to Rao sooner
[Music]